kids don't try this at home let's go hey
man you don't get in the Super Bowl by
not being in 10th I'm gonna take a note
from Isaac and start building wall a
drink yeah why are you doing making
mistakes man ask Picasso what he was
doing get out my balloon idea you're
just building a wizard staff with a
balloon that's losing how much time do
we have left guys are messing I'm
[ __ ] cleaning up 90 seconds oh my god
I can't believe I pulled it out in the
end
how's that cowboy like my burps the best
thing going you really did oh my god
okay you know what this looks like a
[ __ ] mountain I had the most amazing
trophy like of all time I'm pretty sure
except it popped because I got too
aggressive and tried to put hair on it
oh no I'm okay with finishing for in the
15 minutes proud of it
my parents won't be proud but I'm proud
I made this nice cowboy and I was gonna
make him a nice mountain to see undone I
only finished two and a half beers and
I'm like this so that's
and I was really stoked I was i these
guys went straight for the beer I had a
strategy I was gonna blow my balloon up
first the first one kind of ran away
from me
second one popped I was really proud of
this one this was this third one was
gonna be nice it was nice and I like
that my failures are just jokes to you
you bastards feel like I won a bunch of
trophies here they're all around me
[Music]